hello my name is Phil Greenwood I'm a
lecturer at the Business School at the
University of wisconsin-madison in the
Weinert Center for Entrepreneurship and
this presentation is going to be a brief
presentation on biotech entrepreneurship
incorporating there's several different
things our agenda is going to include a
brief overview in specifically talking
about some things pertinent to biotech
entrepreneurship
secondly we'll discuss what I like to
consider a few different illusions about
entrepreneurship mainly certain facts
that exist but also certain myths that
exist thirdly we'll look at some factors
that a lot of investors incorporate for
ventures in general but especially
biotech ventures that make them
attractive as potential investments and
then look at some things like after the
startup going into the future so to
start with biotech entrepreneurship of
course has been really popular probably
since the mid 1970s I believe the first
major biotech firm or one of the first
was Genentech out of the Bay Area and
became very popular very well-known
developed a very successful product line
early on IPO before they got bought out
in the 90s or 2000s by Roche followed by
companies like Amgen and a few others
biotech companies biopharma companies
are unique creatures unto themselves
they they face a heavily regulated
environment a very competitive
environment a very global environment
nowadays and facing lots of lots of
different trends lots of different
things going on in the world and and
domestically in the US that have put a
lot of pressure but yet still create a
lot of opportunity and of course in
entrepreneurship in biotechnology
because it's technology-based there's
always the pressure of new technologies
that
leapfrog or replace current technologies
one of the things we like to talk about
in our entrepreneurship classes in
general especially in dealing with
startups is to provide kind of a brief
overview on certain beliefs that a lot
of the popular press has and I think a
lot of people have they try to point out
realities of startups and such
professor Scott Jain who originally had
done research at the University of
Maryland and has recently been at Case
Western Reserve in in Cleveland has
written a book called the illusions of
entrepreneurship and what he really
studies using economic data and survey
data and a variety of other studies is
to highlight what the where the you know
what's the what are some of the things
people think are true about startups and
small businesses but yet what's the
reality as you can see here one of the
things that Shayne really points out and
he says this is his number one myth or
fact he tries to get across to
entrepreneurs is it's really important
that the success of a start-up isn't
totally reliant on the talent of the
management team or the people involved
but that the industry has a lot to do
with it starting a software company as
opposed to a restaurant the chance for
success and big successes so much is so
much higher in the same thing with a
biotechnology firm depending if you're
in drug discovery or research products
or software can really have a big impact
Sheen also likes to point out that the
average business and remember there's
about 30 million organizations which are
classified as small businesses in
America less than 500 employees now of
that about 25 million are people who are
independent contractors work on their
own or don't have any employees but the
median startup that that the that
decided by Shane from research using
census data the median startup is
capitalized with about $25,000 now
compare this to biotechnology companies
many biotech companies
are started with a small amount of money
just to get get operations started but
as we know the cost low biotechnology
biopharma company is a lot higher to the
regulation and all the technology
involved initially in the in the
beginning stages of startup the majority
of the financing comes from the
entrepreneur savings including mortgages
or second mortgages on their house
relatives a variety of other things also
it's important to know that business is
is typically either going to be a retail
or a service business out of those 30
million it's more likely it's going to
be a hair salon or a clothing store and
it will be you know a biotechnology or a
software firm most founders of small
businesses really expect to make more
than a hundred thousand dollars a year
and I know we'd like to point out that
people start businesses to make millions
and so on and so forth but that usually
doesn't happen it's usually not true
typically things most entrepreneurs go
into business because they want to be on
their own
yeah they want to make money but that's
not the sole driving force and finally
this is one point we try to get across
with with entrepreneurs a lot of small
business owners entrepreneurs depend
regardless of industry don't like the
process of writing a business plan they
believe business plans are worthless
they take too much time things change
too much and so on well shane has shown
through his his research that it really
there is a lot of evidence that exists
that performance measures of startups
are improved if a business plan is
written and he gives several different
reasons but mainly I think it's
self-evident you know provides direction
to a company gets a company to analyze
things just as a little more objectivity
to it now one of the stigmas or things
that's associated with a small business
is the fact a lot of them fail in fact
the Small Business Administration
estimates that of all industries
60% of startups will fail or terminate
within the first five years now what are
some reasons and this is again
regardless of industry what are some
reasons why this happens well as we know
inadequate sales they just never make
enough money to create an income or
recover the expenses of the business
secondly and this is one reason that
happens a lot is a company has too much
growth or too many sales
oh they're unprofitable they can't
control their expenses a variety of
things to go with that thirdly
regardless of the sales levels they
don't control their overhead or their
operating expenses at p2gai of salary
pay too much in marketing whatever
another reason for failure also another
reason that's and if this off often ties
into the first two reasons is they have
receivables different difficulties
meaning they don't they don't collect
from their customers I'm fast enough and
get information cashflow problems
because of that another reason that is
provided by the SBA and others is that
companies fail or terminate us
competitive weakness they just can't
compete against stronger competition
either they don't identify it or they
just never really figure out what the
key success factors are companies that
have retail or manufacturing businesses
that are those they usually one of the
reasons for failure can be inventory
difficulties not just that they have too
much inventory or too little but they
have the wrong kind of inventory of
course when inventory a lot of
businesses is not being sold that's
money that's tied up there are leads to
cashflow problems for retail businesses
especially but this goes for all
businesses location can be a big issue
there's been a lot of study recently
about you know where you locate your
firm if you're a technology to have
business are you better off being in a
Boston or Silicon Valley especially in
the biotech world where you have access
to legal and all the talents and the
universities and such another reason
fixed assets we spend too much money on
capital items like machines like cars
like buildings we spend too much I can't
support it and then the
reason given for failure in businesses
in general or why small businesses only
last majority only last five years is
that gets neglected by management
they just don't spend the proper time
with it now something to note with all
of these reasons why we cover this is
majority these reasons are definitely
they're not simple reasons but they're
easy to understand and they can be
influenced by management there's a lot
management can do to mitigate these
chances and definitely stay in business
now what about biotech tech companies
how are they different now in addition
to those previous eight or ten reasons
just given on the previous slide there's
also other things that biotechs have to
consider biotech startups dr. Emmett kid
gatherin who was the founder of all
theosis in the Bay Area did a nice
little presentation I you see San
Francisco not too many years ago and
cited a lot of data in his presentation
about the biotech startup biotech
environment first he noted that there's
a general thought that biotech startups
have about a 90 percent failure rate now
one thing to note is that's not within
like the first five years but it can go
as far as like 15 years where we find
out whether biotech will actually
succeed or not now the bigger question
is okay outside of being a normal
business why else might the be a reason
for failure well there's a lot of
technology risk and a lot of issues
faced with the clinical process
especially if you're in the drug
development area where you have to go
through the various phases of clinical
approval you have to you know spend lots
of money and also have to you know just
wait your term you have to have a lot of
extra expertise just to be able to do
the clinical trials another reason he
gave well it's just simply the time and
cost the market you know typically 15
years to go through all the approvals
especially if you're going through the
three phases and preclinical and 2012
they estimated that believes this Tufts
Tufts University updated their estimate
to say that to get a product to market
especially in drug discovery those all
two billion dollars I'm sure that's
higher now another reason why biotech
businesses have had a tough time well
there's just less early-stage financing
from venture capitalists a lot of
venture capital funds have found and
their limited partners have found that
it's easier to put money into software
companies or hardware companies where
you don't have to face the regulatory
approvals and don't have the incredible
length of time to wait to see if the
thing really works and then finally
another reason that that the doctor can
go through and talked about was we've
had tremendous change in our regulatory
environment especially with the
Affordable Care Act it's putting a lot
of pressure which isn't necessarily a
bad thing for the consumer but for
companies it's putting pressure on their
ability to make profit facing a lot more
price controls or potential price
controls and just more emphasis on you
know try and try to save money in the
health care environment now while
failure a termination is a big idea to
face we do want to make sure that we
focus on the opposite side of that if
okay what happens if you have an
opportunity an idea especially for a
biotechnology startup being a drug
discovery or whatever one of the things
we always like to get across in our
entrepreneurship courses at the business
school is a quote from Albert Einstein
and and in developing this idea
identifying the opportunity building
your business we in stein once said and
that necessarily that was applicable to
biotech but but era that he was directly
of shooting it to biotech what it kind
of fits is that everything should be
made as simple as possible but not more
so so there's a fine balance in
developing your opportunity in not
making it too complex but yet not
cutting corners in order to make things
work when we start looking at at new
ventures of all type but especially in
biotechnology we really look at for
general things and this is a concept
that was or a framework developed by
William Solomon a professor at Harvard
Business School and entrepreneurial
management entrepreneurial finance
he said basically there's a balance
between four different areas for new
ventures one is the people and the
resources of course the team and the
money involved and so on secondly is the
opportunity you know how big is a market
and such thirdly is the deal you know
how much money is going to be required
how much do we forecast that the the the
investors will make or the company will
generate profits and then in the middle
of the context the macro-environment the
leg legislative items trends that are
taking place maybe many times outside
the control of the company or outside
the control of the industry but Salman's
sites that we have to go through and
balance all four of these in order to
create or at least to identify a solid
opportunity and when we write plans when
we present when we discuss investors we
got to make sure that we hit all these
now kind of a framework that I use in
evaluating new venture opportunities is
something called the outside impacts
approach that's an acronym believe it or
not the outside impacts approach is a is
a framework that was developed by
Professor Steven Kaplan out of the
University of Chicago who teaches an
entrepreneurial finance and is a major
leader of their new venture creation
business plan competition and such he's
developed his checklist that he sees is
valuable not only in teaching to
potential entrepreneurs but also he's
found it to be very valuable when
working with investors to teach them
kind of a quick and dirty checklist to
help get through different help evaluate
opportunities in a relatively quick
basis now you have to understand that
with a lot of especially venture capital
funds who are ultimately our investors
in biotech not of biotechnology
businesses they may look at 2,000 to
4,000 or more different proposals per
year many times those funds don't have
too many people and don't have the
resources to spend lots of time in a
value
so what they need is a checklist or what
we call a first cut feasibility tool to
weed through those 2,000 to 4,000
opportunities and to help select a good
10 or 20 different potential investments
that they can perform further type of
analysis so let's just quickly go
through some of the components of the
outside impacts again this is a this is
a acronym and as you can see the seven
major components of outside is to first
look at the opportunity again we'll
we'll delve into this greater detail in
the next few minutes but one of the
great things people have to identify
with is is there an opportunity and the
items in the item the things that go
with that secondly we have to look at
the uncertainty associated with the
venture or idea and what steps can be
taken to lessen the opportunity or the
uncertainty and the opportunity thirdly
of course the team fourth the strategy
that's being employed employed by the
company is at the right 150 investment
that goes with that and the D is the
deal structure that's associated with
that and then finally what kind of exit
opportunity is available for the
investors and what Kaplan says is that
all seven of these items have to be
addressed and they should not have
negative answers with them so in other
words we should not have a negative
response or negative analysis associated
with the team or any of the items or if
there is a negative we pass on the deal
now the most important part of the
outside framework is the opportunity or
the what we call the impacts associated
with this again think of impacts as an
acronym the I portion says what is the
idea in the industry and what we're what
they typically are asking is can the
entrepreneur can the team explain the
idea of the venture of the technology
very clearly and concise
but secondly isn't in the type of
industry is it in the same industry that
we invest in a lot of times one of the
quickest ways that investors will pass
and not invest in a company is they'll
simply say you know we're not in we're
not into the biotech space we're only in
software or or vice versa that'll be one
of the quickest ways they screen through
opportunities the second component of
the impacts which is tied to opportunity
is you know as the market large enough
to support substantial growth in other
words you know is this only a 50 million
dollar a year market or is it something
that could ultimately grow to a hundred
million or five hundred million or more
and is this a idea that might be able to
get you know five or ten percent market
share to create a sizable enough sales
base for the company and profits along
with it to support an investment in it
secondly you've got a look at within the
market growth opportunities not just the
size and how fast it's growing but also
can it support evaluation in other words
is this a profitable market that will be
able to if this company ever gets sold
or if it ever goes public I can support
a good stock price the pport is you know
does it generate positive present value
not just in financial terms but I unique
value proposition for customers
has it been accepted in the marketplace
or can you show that it's been accepted
not just through research but trial and
error and such will the customers buy
this again in biotech this might be a
little bit difficult because you have to
go through the through the preclinical
and so on phases the C portion of
impacts is is there any chance that
competition could come into this play
you know is there a intellectual
property that protects the technology or
are you far enough ahead of competition
that you can protect yourself and the
company won't be put out of existence
relatively quick is this a good time to
enter for the company why now why hasn't
this been done before is it too early
is it too late we have to answer those
questions and then finally associated
with the opportunity is the S or the
speed how quickly can this be done now
in general with non biotech companies
they may be looking at a time frame of a
year to three years can this be you know
can the technology be implemented that
quick or is it gonna be something that
takes too long for our investment
horizon now of course in drug discovery
biopharma and such you might be talking
a 10 or 15 year product development
cycle well can that be done on that
length of time but also can there be
alternative at least can you show
progress in the time horizon of the
investors now within the opportunity
impacts portion what capelin suggests is
that all of the Impa cts has to be
positive or at least no negatives if any
of those items are negative or don't
meet our criteria then we we say the
opportunity is not one we're gonna
pursue and we pass out and going down to
our next company the second area within
the outside approach outside impacts
approach is the uncertainty one of the
things that we have to identify is okay
how certain we are are we about the size
that the market will become or that
customers really will accept us and in
biotechnology that's really tough
because you know we have to try to look
out 10 and 15 years into the future to
see if people will really get at that
more importantly though it's not just
identify sort the uncertainties but are
there steps that we can take to help
manage it like can we align with certain
customers who will work with us in
developing the product are there types
of investors strategic investors who can
help offset some of the risk or provide
you know a certain type of of expertise
and you know how how understanding that
just what the uncertainties are but what
we can do to hopefully reduce the
uncertainties how is this gonna affect
the opportunity if for instance we find
out the market size is gonna be 50
million instead of 200 million do we
still have a chance to make enough
profit from an investment standpoint
so from uncertainty you go to the team I
think we people cover this a lot you
know you look at the things like the
previous experience of the team the
thing I really look for and I think a
lot of people a lot of investors do
within a management team of a new
biotech ventures
how passionate are they are they hungry
do they have you know have they put a
lot of time in this are they working
100% toward this venture
do they have some stock ownership or
have they invested themselves and to
realize that yeah we don't need to hire
everybody right away but what pieces
will need to be added and what type of
people will be needed to fill those
things and it's a company planning for
that so you've got opportunity
uncertainty the team the fourth and
fifth component is the strategy so are
we is the company have a strategy in
place that's is it aligned properly with
the opportunity the uncertainty of the
team and the exit does the team have the
experience to implement the strategy
from the investment standpoint you know
are they asking for enough or too little
money believe it or not it happens a lot
where new ventures don't ask for enough
money and it shows the lack of
experience of the founders of the
management team or if they don't ask it
they might be asking for too much and it
goes beyond what the investors can
handle believe it believe it or not also
that a lot of investors have a minimum
threshold especially venture capital
firms well they may say we have to put
in at least X amount of million into a
company to make it worthwhile otherwise
it's too small for us to manage in
addition to the investment side of it
you know what about the cash flow
forecasts do they have a for pro forma
cash flow forecast over three or five
years do they make sense you know if if
there's not going to be revenue right
away how are they going to manage their
expenses to control them you know to
make sure that they're spending enough
to push the product along on the 15 year
product lifecycle product development
cycle in biotech or or not gonna you
know that they're making
progress so all those things we looked
at in addition finally Kaplan recommends
that you look at the deal and the exit
strategy with the deal you're looking at
what type of financing is it is a
preferred stock is it a convertible loan
that can be changed from a debt you know
alone into into equity is a common stock
other incentives in place for the
management team and the investors so
everybody's kind of going along the same
wavelength is there government's
governance in place in other words you
know maybe there's a board seat that
should be added to this investment or or
what is that what is who is on the board
and how is the governance of the company
managed and finally what's in place to
manage the financial uncertainties and
especially in biotechnology where we can
talk incredible sums of money that need
to be invested are the investment are
they are they is the management team
asking for all the money up front
are they splitting it up into chunks or
tranches do they have the ability to
syndicate the investment so bring in
several investors not just one so all
those things have to be looked at it
from a deal standpoint not just the
percentage ownership at the valuation
and then finally the e is the exit you
know is this gonna be a company that can
do a public offering an IPO or is it
somebody who can be bought out you know
a merger and acquisition or is it gonna
be something it's just not big enough
that it'll ever want to exit or maybe
the entrepreneurs who start the company
don't want to go through a sale or an
IPO all those things have to be hashed
out and are part of an important part of
the deal so in the end
Kaplan recommends that investors if if
all the items the o UTS IDE don't come
out positive or at least there's no
negatives if there's any one of those
negative they pass on the deal in other
words they leave it outside other things
that biotech or venture capitalists will
look at in biotech
is what we call that an x-factor can
they put money into this company and in
five to seven years get ten times its
money back also things you want to look
at is the founders dilemma in other
words people who start these companies
be aware of what happens to their role
on the company as time goes on the 10 X
Factor all it really says is can we get
10 times our investment back in other
words for instance if we put in a
million dollars in a company this year
five years out can we get 10 million
dollars out of it in other words when
they sell the company when they do the
IPO with a percentage of stock that we
own you know can we get that much money
back now what why this is important is
that a lot of times investors don't talk
in terms of we want to insane things
like we want a 15% return on our
investment or we need a 15 percent IRR
in other words typically they'll say we
want a 5x or a 10x return well it's
important to note that that's what they
want and that's what they mean but also
it also points to if they can get a 10x
return in five years is that having to
invest any more money that's about a 60%
annual rate of return and for a lot of
people a lot of a lot of entrepreneurs
who haven't been dealing with venture
capitalists very much this is kind of
when they hear that that equalized
interest rate or internal rate of return
it tends to set them back a little bit
to think people need that kind of return
on their investment isn't that a little
high when you I can go to my bank and
get a loan for 5% or you know relatives
will will invest and only want like 10
or 15 percent annual rate of return but
there's a reason for that it's because
people in the venture capital industry
typically in a fund that they have will
invest in about 10 to 15 companies and
historically out of their fund usually
only one or two of those investments
will actually make money in other words
be home runs
so they'd have to use some big threshold
to try to identify what attractive
investments are because even after they
make the investment because every
company they'll have in their portfolio
will have passed this sixty percent
annual rate of return or at least the
potential for a 10x return only one if
one or two of them will actually
generate that the remaining 80% will
either lose all their money or most of
the money or maybe just return the
principle to them and what's critical
for investors especially in biotech
companies is they need a liquidity event
in other words the company better
planned to do an IPO in five to seven
years or better plan to be sold to a
larger biopharma company or something
and if they don't plan for that or it's
not in the cards that makes a less
attractive attractive less attractive
investment secondly when talking about
the 10x factor investors get very
concerned about are they gonna need a
lot more investment money after they
make their original original investment
and will that dilute down their
percentage ownership because what'll
really drive the value of their
investment is not only the overall value
of the company but what percentage they
own is that if the company seat needs
additional lots of financing and the
investor can't put much more in after
their initial chunk that they invest in
they could get reduced down to a very
small percentage ownership and really
decrease their chances for getting a big
return on their investment a third thing
that comes into play with this 10x rule
or criteria is that it really shows
companies especially in biotech Pharma
biopharma they have to be in markets
that have really large potential market
values or market potential in other
words they better be in industries that
might be able to create like a that the
overall market will be a billion dollars
in sales at some point in the future and
that this investment whoever owns that
will be able to get a good chunk of that
so all these things come into play
now a second thing that biotech
entrepreneur should really be concerned
with is something we call the founders
dilemma
the founders dilemma was a framework a
concept developed by a norm Wasserman
who was a professor at the Harvard
Business School now he's at at
university of southern california in his
research in the late 1990s early 2000s
he studied PI technology companies and
who eventually did IPOs initial public
offerings and wanted to find out what
happened to the management team as these
as these startups moved along and
eventually did the IPOs he analyzed the
few hundred different startups in the
u.s. he found one of the key things he
found and why he called it the founders
dilemma is that by the time ventures
were these ventures were 3 years old 50
percent of the founders of the companies
were no longer the CEOs in other words
investors had either fired him or they
had moved them into a less into a
position with less authority even in
year 4 only 40 percent were still in in
their corner office or 60 percent were
gone and then typically after the IPO
which happened after the fifth year only
25 percent of the founders remain so
ultimately Wasserman's found that four
out of five entrepreneurs typically are
forced out by investors from their CEO
post he also found as part of his
research and also this is correlated
with other researches and a couple other
journals is that usually entrepreneurs
even in high tech biotech companies
never make as much money or make just as
much money as the employees that work
for them so the misnomer that
entrepreneurs who start biotech
companies are going to be millionaires
and billionaires someday it's typically
not right Wasserman showed in other
research of 528 companies that over half
of the entrepreneurs made less
then at least one person who reported to
them and so things to conclude out of
this is that typically founders are
probably in biotech companies that
receive outside investment and I'm gonna
go down the path of an IPO or an
acquisition most founders are going to
be pushed out of their job secondly
they're not going to make a lot of money
additionally what wasserman tried to
identify what what the problem was he
said most entrepreneurs were too over
overconfident when they started their
company about what the process of
prospects were they were way too
confident and that they would be able to
stay CEO regardless of what happened and
be able to manage the business into the
long term now are any Cooper and other
researchers at you know University
correlated this this research by asking
3,000 entrepreneurs about what they
expected of their future prospects 81%
were confident of their own success and
that they would stay with their company
and over 60 almost 60% were were
confident of success in similar ventures
so in other words most entrepreneurs
especially in the biotech space tend to
be overconfident not realistic about
what their role will be in the long term
long term venture now what Wasserman
recommended and then what he part of
what he concluded from his research is
that investors and entrepreneurs must
realize that there is a control versus
wealth trade-off typically companies
that made that had higher value and also
the entrepreneurs were able to stick
around long enough the entrepreneurs had
to face the what they called the rich
versus king or queen trade-off in other
words did the entrepreneur just want to
be wealthy and want the company to be
wealthy or was control the major issue
did the entrepreneur want to stay you
know in control of the organization what
wasserman found out is that the
entrepreneurs who tended to be less
control oriented and more more more
concerned about creating wealth for
themselves and everybody associated with
the venture they tended to succeed in
the
venture tended to do well after the IPO
are better in the IPO he also found that
investors use a lot of mechanisms to
through control mechanisms to make sure
that they can maximize their wealth in
other words things like putting together
employment agreements for CEOs or being
on the board of directors and such and
then finally as part of the financing
agreements that's where this is
typically decided when doing investments
so that's kind of a brief overview of
you know just some things about
entrepreneurship a little bit of data on
biotechnology entrepreneurship and then
some research that's happened after the
fact what investors look for dilemmas
that are faced by founders in firms
including biotech firms and and and
other things associated with what
happens after a biotech startup moves
along the development path receives
money and and so on